hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we are back island for honor again
and today should be the second upload of
the day and if you're wondering yes I
literally just started this video as I
ended the gladiator one so we're just
starting a new one up and the focus of
today's video is to show off the new
Wulin mythic outfit now this I believe
is a specific mythic outfit to the Wulin
I love it and it's called The Dreaming
blossom and it has this little red petal
lotus flower I'm not entirely sure what
the actual flower is but it's really
cool and it just comes up at the bottom
something really minor something really
cool 15-thousand steel cross your boys
gonna buy for JJ because JJ's best
character in the game totally not a bias
thing so yeah guys we're gonna be
playing some breach as always just like
the last video gonna be doing a couple
games maybe one game or so and then
cutting up the good part so that you
don't waste your time and yeah we're
gonna be playing with the new effects
showing it off let's get started with
the game yeah guys the match has started
we've I think we just started the game
which is a good one it just kind of
started but I wasn't at the very
beginning so just to show it off in game
this is the mythic outfit it actually
looks way better in person I would say
because it's not as bright I would
definitely say it's I would say it's a
little bit darker toned and it's really
funny if I spam it I find this really
cool cause it just spurts out like red
liquid that's not that's not a sex joke
don't take it as that maybe not kick him
real quick I almost gave that guy
revenge
I apologize team shaman you're trash get
out my face hit it with the zone she has
no idea what's going on she has no idea
what's going on dude change it JJ is too
powerful and too thick
got her with the execution perfect I was
hoping that she would miss the timing on
that she did it's not bad I wouldn't say
that this mythic outfit personal review
of just the you know face value like
this I would say that I don't know I'd
say that this act this mythic outfit is
really cool as an idol it's really cool
as an idol it's pretty nice as a emote
as well I wouldn't say it's the greatest
though for executions mostly because you
can't really see it defend I mean this
could just be depending on my execution
I just could have had a bad taste of it
but I've never been really good on
executions like this or you know effects
that are similar to this and with
executions I usually just go with idle
and emotes and stuff now you're gonna
eat that heavy arm [ __ ] you're gonna eat
this seafoods poised you're gonna do it
again aren't you a good plan good play
ah she let it rip I'm sleep we got the
gate destroyed that's good we're on the
Phase two now we've 35 lives that's
actually a crazy amount of help so our
that's a crazy amount of lives that's
really good hopefully we can keep this
momentum going hopefully get this win
got that nice lob rear with that cape
okay macdaddy meadow all right love the
new law printer armor I definitely think
a lot of people are gonna start playing
lob ringer just for the armor sake but
honestly they're probably gonna realize
they stole a bad character but still
great-looking armor I love the cape
honestly makes him just a slightly
better character in my opinion
I fell for the bait there well I almost
fell for the bait but I got it I managed
to realize that most new shows whenever
they throw neutral heavies ie just the
first move that they throw from there
just from neutral like this is just a
heavy tag in case you didn't know what a
neutral meant usually whenever they do
that that was trying to flow into a zone
especially when you're very low Earth
they try to throw into the trap
especially when you're low on health
that's one of their greatest moves is
using Matt Biondi [ __ ] collapsed me
because he has every kit in the game but
I noticed a lot of new shows like to do
that so honestly I just I don't care if
I get hit by the damage I come and just
take the risk and don't block it and I
just go up and I in it yeah and it works
nine times out of ten
give me execution showing off more of
that rose but it gets interrupting you
[ __ ] I refuse
just because I'm gonna lay waste to this
poor officer I like it oh hell for that
one buddy
[ __ ] while he takes his time respawning
I'm gonna go capture this help off
actually no I don't need it I'm gonna
capture it later right now I have a
one-on-one fight with mr. big man over
here hi there guy I think it's it's
definitely zone attack and then heavy is
the best stuffer at least JJ you should
want on a stamina real quick though but
it's the thing his thing he can do oh
[ __ ] he smacked me how'd that miss I am
off I'm dead now oh never mind so I
guess he doesn't actually gain health
and revenge it might just be like the
revenge jump part are you like you get
smacked which sucks but it's okay this
guardian angel just kind of let him and
do the moves and you just counter-attack
every time she's thrown about yourself
bro I think the top heavy is the most
damaging so I'm actually gonna try that
close it again
indeed it is by an extra five damage and
he did it again this scumbag no I'm not
dying this close dude no oh you gotta be
[ __ ] a dude I am going to leave this
game kill myself and just never play for
honor again [ __ ] dude misty on DS
taunted my body in his well that sucks
bro I had that whole flight tianni was
probably watching outside waiting for me
and I'm so [ __ ] pissed
[Music]
this ain't good
this ain't good
that ain't good make it [ __ ] I killed
myself that I end up killing all right
well at least we got that I'll take that
that's fine to me
we have tons of options in terms of D
buffs and health so Ivan I am totally
confident that we can win this or
actually like this drawing this JJ
alright we're destroying this D on D but
JJ is such a good player for fob
character pores I wouldn't say he was
necessary but his feats are really
making him seem like a necessary
character in for befores meeting could
affected did he I'm [ __ ] annoyed oh
we slightly on fire all right my my
efforts counted maybe not as much as I'd
like but they counted
well I'm just killed right there just
[ __ ] tanked right through that bomb
oh I'm on the floor
I know Shaolin you [ __ ] I was so close
to get in Lucia I was very close to
hitting new show with my light attack
that would have ended her but Shaolin
came in with the cake to save his
teammate I'm gonna use my my heal our my
damage buff on the commander get that
damaged damn there goes my health
damn commanders so close he's like one
shot he practically killed himself
we're almost there though it's a big big
push so literally once happened he's
done so they're gonna be playing full on
defense for this one wall bringers
chucking a bomb from half court with the
Kobe didn't work though he's going for
the full arm if four of us good smack I
was gonna say if four of us came from
all different directions we would have
had back cuz that was a that was
definitely in our favor but good stuff
three James June's with the same
signature who would have thought you
guys hopefully guys did enjoy the video
today just wanted to show off the new
mythic outfit that comes with all the
woodland characters every some member
every single character of the Wulin
faction gets it but I specifically like
playing James June so I didn't want to
show that off for a bit I thought it was
really cool to show off loving this
character so far definitely enjoying him
I can't wait to get him to the higher
reps very excited to play more if I'm
already evolved 14 so if I had a little
bit of time like I did I had to go to a
meeting today I probably would've been
rep one by now but that doesn't matter
because we're gonna still be pushing out
content stuff like that
hey guys hope you guys did enjoy that
video like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being balance changes hero updates patch
notes leaks and all that type of stuff
like that as well as some gameplay in
the background and stuff like that as
well that guys my two most recent videos
would be on screen if you guys do want
to check that out with the guys have a
great yesterday thank you for watching
the video and peace out
[Music]